uh i want to play for you
uh a fascinating video um the ukrainian
president vladimir zelensky spoke
yesterday via uh uh
you know satellite uplink or or maybe
over the internet via teleconference
with um or to british parliament and
received a standing ovation and we're
going to just kind of catch up on a few
of the different things that took place
over the last 24 hours uh here is uh the
russian president the ukrainian
president rather addressing you british
parliament about the russian invasion of
his country ukraine
for your help
for the help of the civilized
countries
we are we are thankful for this help
and i'm very grateful to you boris
please increase the pressure of
sanctions
against this
country and police recognize this
country as a terrorist state
and please make sure that our ukrainian
skies are safe
please make sure
you do
what needs to be done
and
what is stipulated by the greatness of
your country
best of all to ukraine and
to the united kingdom
it's
truly remarkable that a president who by
all accounts and i'm talking about
zolensky here
was
sort of okay you know before this and
not particularly well liked has
rapidly become
a hero
not only
within ukraine
but internationally and we can debate
whether in the totality of what is
zelensky's legacy
that makes sense
uh it is not really the debate for today
because it is what is happening uh being
being held up as a hero and i mean
listen uh when you look at what he's
doing he uh every opportunity to have
left and so many other things that that
he chose to do which he didn't have to i
understand why this is the reaction
regardless of what our thoughts about
zolensky would have been even as
recently as six weeks ago now what is
happening in the russian invasion of
ukraine we are learning about yet
another one of these columns of armored
vehicles and tanks pushing further into
ukraine
we are learning about the refugee crisis
of individuals leaving ukraine many as
quickly as they possibly can on trains
even walking over the border i was
watching as i often do argentinian news
and uh argentina has reporters on the
ukrainian polish border
and i mean just children walking across
the border truly heartbreaking images
in terms of the economic sanctions
yesterday i reported to you that the
united states is banning
russian oil imports and we'll have video
a little bit later of joe biden
announcing that we also have now learned
that the united kingdom will be banning
russian oil imports as well
in a new sanctions move when you look at
a map like the one we have on the screen
right now
you see the significant dependence on
russian oil
from much of eastern europe in
particular poland and hungary and and
other countries
western europe much less reliant on
russian oil and so uh saying we are not
going to
um
accept russian oil imports a much less
impactful decision although still having
a major impact on oil markets also over
the last 24 hours
maria baranova
the
now former editor-in-chief of russia
today which is state-run media
you might know it as rt
maria baranova has now resigned as the
editor-in-chief of rt
after condemning the invasion of ukraine
she is well aware that anyone who speaks
out against the kremlin could be in
danger but personal safety is the least
of her concerns uh she said the problem
is i know these people very well they
never send threats they just kill so
there is a kind of weird silence around
me but i really think we're on the brink
of a nuclear war right now i'm not
exaggerating i have a son i can't leave
because his father won't allow me to
leave with him so i just prefer to stay
in moscow it seems like we're either in
north korea or we're going to be killed
by a thermonuclear mushroom i wouldn't
quit
and i wouldn't lose my salary and job if
i were sure that we are going to be
alive for many years but i really don't
know what is going to happen to all of
us next
unbelievable
unbelievable situation and uh you know
at the at the beginning the question was
would will this be days or will this be
weeks
more recently the conversation is will
this be weeks or will it be months with
some
uh analyses from foreign ministries
briefing lawmakers that this could be
years to some degree
so we will watch it every 24 hours
bringing significant news
and the refugee crisis is getting
absolutely heartbreaking to an even
greater extent than it was last week
and we're going to talk about more uh
we'll talk more about the refugee
situation on tomorrow's show in the
meantime let me know how long do you
believe the current state of affairs
will last in ukraine let me know on
twitter where you can find me at d
pacman